[Music]
our top story tonight Roseann bars new
rent she told us that she was going to
talk about the controversy that got her
fired and her show canceled but man oh
man keV I don't think anyone expected
her to go off the rails yes that is
audible laughing in the background
immediately after a seemingly unhinged
Roseann attempts to clarify the racist
tweet they got her fired
you told me this 300 times do you know
that was about the disturbing unedited
one-minute video was posted to her
YouTube page last night the 65 year old
appears agitated while smoking a
cigarette a male voice is heard
off-camera giving the comic
unconventional media coaching whatever
this afternoon a second video was posted
this one she called her official
statement I'm able to speak for myself
without the filter of the biased media
delivering what appears to be a scripted
message Roseann claims ABC's decision to
pull the plug on her hugely successful
show was politically motivated my show
was canceled then I was labeled a racist
why you ask well the answer is simple
it's because I voted for Donald Trump
here's what we know about the video
timeline 11 days ago on July 9th
Roseanne tweeted she was backing out of
a plan TV interview explaining she
wanted to release her own content on
YouTube two days later on July 11th
Roseanne son Jake requested questions
from fans if you have questions you'd
like her to answer you can send them if
you're an attractive woman you can also
send nudes because I'm the one checking
last Friday production appeared to be
underway Jake posted to Instagram this
behind the scenes footage in which
Roseanne appears calm and sincere thanks
wanting to hear what I have to say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]